[Music]
whenever I think of words like museum or
an institution I think of a common place
for people to come together irrespective
of their religion or caste or race or
whatever it might be or sexuality
without someone dictating to them what
it is that they should be seeing or
should be feeling you end up having this
really common experience with everybody
in that space I love doing this which is
you know I think what a lot of actors
love doing observing and he just stand
there and you just look at people's
faces and how a certain piece of art
appeals to someone and someone else's
walks away from it but something else is
you know they get drawn to it film is
such a universal language every country
in every part of the world has its own
film industry for the Academy to bring
together the world of filmmaking all
under one roof allows people to come to
this one institution that one place and
have that feeling that experiencial
feeling with other people in the same
room
[Music]
you